As before, we have a red Poisson
process and a green Poisson
process.
We merge these two
processes, and we only
observe the merged process.
Here's an interesting question.
This is an arrival of
the merged process.
Where did it come from?
Is it red, or is it green?
We cannot know, but can we tell
what is the probability that it
came from the red stream?
The way to answer
this question is
to look at the table
of all the things
that can happen during
a little interval
around that particular time
in which we had an arrival.
We are told that there was an
arrival at time t or an arrival
during an interval, a small
interval around time t.
This means that we're told that
this event here has happened.
Given this information, what
is the conditional probability
that actually this
event here occurred?
This is just the fraction
of this probability divided
by the total probability
of the conditioning event.
So the answer is
lambda 1 divided
by lambda 1 plus lambda 2.
Does this answer make sense?
Well, suppose that lambda
1 and lambda 2 were equal.
In that case, by symmetry,
when an arrival comes,
it should be equally likely to
have come either from the red
or from the green stream.
And this is consistent
with this answer.
We can reason similarly for a
slightly different question.
You wait until the kth arrival,
let's say the third arrival.
Where did that
arrival come from?
Well, that case,
arrival occurred
during a specific little time
interval and conditioning
on it having occurred during
that particular time interval,
we can then repeat the reasoning
that we had here and argue
that given that we had an
arrival-- it just happens
to be the third arrival
during that time interval--
there's going to be this
particular conditional
probability that it came
from the red stream.
So we obtained the
same answer once more.
Now, this arrival came
from one of the two streams
with some probabilities.
This arrival came from
one of the two streams
with some probabilities.
Does the origin of this
arrival affect or depend
on the origin of that arrival?
Because we have
assumed independence
across time for each
one of the processes
that we started with--
and therefore, we also
have the same thing for the
merged process-- whatever
has to do with events
during this interval
is independent
from anything that
has to do with events
in that interval.
And because of this, one
could argue formally--
but hopefully, this
is intuitive enough--
that the origin of this arrival
and the origin of that arrival
are independent events.
And now that we
have this property,
we can answer questions
such as the following.
We've had 10 arrivals so far.
What is the probability that
exactly four out of these 10
are red?
Each one of those arrivals has
this probability of being red.
The origin of different arrivals
are independent of each other.
So essentially, we're dealing
with 10 Bernoulli trials,
each of which has two possible
outcomes, red or green,
and is red with this
particular probability.
Therefore, the
answer is going to be
given by the binomial
probabilities, which
is the probability of having
four successes in 10 trials.
And we obtain lambda 1 over
lambda 1 plus lambda 2.
That's the probability of a red
to the number of red arrivals.
And then the
remaining probability,
1 minus that, which is
lambda 2 over lambda 1
plus lambda 2 to the remaining
power, which is equal to 6.
So to summarize.
Each one of the arrivals
in the merged process
has a certain
probability of being
a red arrival or
a green arrival.
Which one of the
two is the case?
We can think of it as an
outcome of Bernoulli trial,
and the Bernoulli
trials associated
with different arrivals are
independent of each other
as a consequence of the
independence of Poisson
processes across time.